super simple hassle-free recipe is
cooked all in one pot start by Browning
chunks of lamb in hot olive oil
color and remove
then fried onions
season
add chopped garlic ground ginger and
coriander
a teaspoon of whole cumin seeds
paprika and fennel seeds a cinnamon
stick bay leaf and delicate strands of
saffron then fry to release all the
aromatic flavors
next add tomato puree
chunks of sweet potato and the juicy
Brown lamb
for a sweet note add plump raisins then
cover with stock and simply leave to
simmer for a couple of hours
delicious eaten straight away but over
time the flavors will develop and
improve
when you're ready to serve simply finish
with fresh parsley